problem with empathy is that it's easy
and easily manipulated because it is
mostly an emotional response you can
easily fool yourself that you're
actually in the you know in somebody
else's shoes while you act in fact
you're not so sympathy means that you
are trying to be uh helpful to other
people you're trying to understand how
other people might be going through
let's say a tough time and and how you
might be helpful but at the same time
you realize you're not them you're not
you're not in that situation the case of
social media uh it turns out they're not
neutral neutral platforms they're not
it's not just a matter of how you use it
uh it's it's there's something
structurally built into the system that
biases behaviors of many people not
everybody necessarily but a lot of
people in a direction that I think is
destructive and so my response was I'm
done I'm out of it it is the rise of
social media that has made Trump
possible but also has made the outrage
culture possible the easily offended
culture possible etc etc I mean you know
I don't know whether social media is the
beginning of the end of civilization I
certainly hope not but it is a problem
and we really ought to fight back
against against it
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is a
professor of philosophy at the City
College of New York he also has a PHD in
evolutionary biology and he's the author
of 16 books Massimo piuti welcome to
trigonometry thanks it's a pleasure to
be here it's really great to have you on
the show we're going to get into all the
philosophy the stoicism how to live a
good life all that great stuff in a
second before that just tell everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey through life
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
oh sure that's a short question uh let's
see I am a professor of philosophy of
science actually at the City College of
New York
but before that I was an evolutionary
biologist for about 20 years and uh how
I got here it's a complicated Journey
that started in West Africa where I was
born and moved to Rome where I grew up
and then eventually over to the United
States for my biology career and then
finally in the New York area as a
philosopher I was just about to say you
look very African yeah but welcome to
the show it's really great to have you
on and one of the fascinating things
about you is you combine evolutionary
biology and we've had a number of
evolutionary biologists on the show uh
with the philosophy uh which seems to me
actually very complementary skill sets
is that fair to say
I think that's fair I mean one of the
advantages that I have uh in this field
is that I'm one of those rare
philosophers who have actually been
scientists and actually have been in the
lab and doing experiments have practical
experience you know hands-on experience
of how you actually do science and at
the same time I'm one of those
scientists rare in my experience
scientists who actually have the luxury
of stepping back and looking at things
from a broader perspective and say oh
okay so this is what we're doing and why
we're doing it
fantastic so you were an evolutionary
biologist you segued it into philosophy
very quickly how how does that affect
your the way that you approach
philosophy the way that you approach
your practice the fact that you're an
evolutionary biologist does that
influence you in any shape or form
yeah it better I think uh the the whole
notion of Science in general but of
biology in particular is that whatever
you're interested in let's say in this
particular case I've been spending the
last few years as you know in sort of
what they call practical philosophy
um yeah but it helps having some
understanding of how the world actually
works because after all we're trying to
navigate the world as it is not as we
would like it to be or or as it would be
in an idealized form so yes having an
understanding particularly of biology
because it helps you position human
beings as a species in a broader context
that have an understanding of where we
came from more or less and and what we
are all about so that certainly is going
to give perspective even when it comes
to uh tackling everyday problems like oh
I have this urge maybe that's because
and then you you tell yourself a story
that makes more sense of what's
happening to you
and that leads us very neatly into
stoicism and the beliefs around stoicism
so as somebody who has never studied
philosophy and who is an absolute Layman
as will be most of our viewers and
listeners what is stoicism
is an ancient gregoroman philosophy that
has the goal of uh helping us to find a
happy life
in some respects I think of it as the
Western equivalent of Buddhism and in
fact there are a lot of similarities
between between the two approaches in
terms of Ethics that is in terms of how
to lead your life they're very different
in terms of their metaphysics that is in
terms of how they see how the world
works but fundamental historicism is
about giving you a compass a moral
compass to navigate your life in the
best possible way and that Compass is
based on four cardinal virtues virtues
are character traits they're they're
behavioral Tendencies or dispositions
and there is a number of them that have
been named and and studied over the
Millennia literally both in the western
traditions and in eastern Traditions but
the stoics focus on four practical
wisdom courage Justice and Temperance
practical wisdom is the knowledge of
what is good and what is not good
which you think is fundamental if you
don't have an idea of what you should be
pursuing and what you should be staying
away from then you're really in trouble
so nothing else really matters once you
settle that one and we might talk about
a little bit more about how the stoics
actually settled that one then the other
three come in and as I said they are
courage courage is the notion that you
want to do things that are you know the
right things even though it might cost
you at a personal level
Justice is the notion that you should be
treating other people fairly with
respect uh just in the way which you
would want to be treated and Temperance
is the idea that you need to do things
in right measure neither too much nor
too little and so as a stoic you
constantly ask yourself okay am I is is
what am I thinking of doing here or my
course of action does it fit the four
cardinal virtues if the answer is yes
you do it if the answer is no you don't
uh and as an evolutionary biologist one
of the things you'll be very familiar
with is the fact that people evolved to
act in the way that they act quite often
uh and uh how does how does any
philosophy really but particularly this
one which seems quite uh intellectual
reckon with the fact that human beings
that you know we've had the Dr Robert
Plowman on the show talked about how
much of our behavior is genetically
predefined how does one reckon with the
fact that quite often you have a genetic
predisposition to do or not do certain
things that may or may not be
practically wise courageous just and and
temperate
well there's two responses there first
of all actually my area of interest in
biology was Gene environment
interactions that is nature nurture and
I am always keptical skeptical of any
claim of this human behavior is largely
genetically determined or is not largely
determined we really don't know because
most of the times we can't do the proper
experiments in order to actually figure
out how Gene genes and environments
interact you will need to start out with
a specific breeding program so that you
get it you know a set of offspring that
are obtained in a certain way then you
have to be able to grow those Offspring
under contrasting environments in the
control condition you can't do anything
like that in human beings both for
practical reasons we have a long life
span so it would take 25 years at least
in that experiment and also more
importantly perhaps for ethical reasons
you know you can't you know keep just
going around breeding people uh in the
way you like them and then draw them
under control condition so we do know
something about Gene environment
interactions human beings but nowhere
near as much as we would want to which
means that as far as these kind of
practical discussions are concerned I
think we should be agnostic we really
don't know how much any specific
behavior is in fact genetically
influenced or not that said no matter
what the behavior here is the there is
pretty good evidence in animal studies
in general
that almost any Behavior especially in
complex animals like mammals is subject
to even when it is when there is
indication that there is a strong
genetic component is still subject to
plasticity what is called plasticity
that is uh flexibility it can still be
altered within certain range of course I
mean it's not we can start flying all of
a sudden and we're not we're not
genetically capable of flying so we're
not going to do that
so the focus for these discussions in
terms of practical philosophy should
really be on well can we in fact alter
our character can we in fact alter our
behavioral dispositions and to what
extent and the answer is to the first
question is clearly yes there is plenty
of evidence from cognitive science that
yes we can alter even though we have we
certainly do have dispositions uh we can
alter them we can work on them
consciously one of the the things the
interesting things about human beings is
that uh unlike as far as we can tell
most other animal species we can
actually reflect critically on our own
behavior and say no this is not
acceptable I'm not going to do it we all
have for instance a very strong instant
for survival which is strictly natural
and certain genetically determined I
mean there's no I don't think there is
much of a question about it we share it
with pretty much every other uh animal
species and yet we can sacrifice
willingly our life if uh if we think
that there is a good enough reason or at
least putting put ourselves in in
potentially mortal danger if we think
that there is enough of a good reason so
we can act I think in in um in certain
respects in a way that overrides
our genetic instance I still remember
even a
fairly strong evolutionary psychologist
like Stephen Pinker years ago he wrote
that you know he made a decision in his
life not to have children and instead to
devote himself to science and and
writing and his comment was and if they
if my genes don't like it they can go
jump into the lake so if if a strong
evolutionary psychologist like Stephen
can say that I think we're on on Good
Grounds we're okay well maybe he doesn't
like kids stuff it could be as simple as
that uh but uh Massimo so that being the
case we've established that to some
extent we are in control of our own
behavior and our choices uh practical
wisdom strikes me as fundamental to all
human life really
um so how how do you how do you become
practically wise
uh practice practice practice so so
turns out that this discussion about you
know can you teach virtual can you learn
virtue to be more virtuous it's been
going on for literally two and a half
Millennia it was studied by Socrates
back in Athens in in the 5th Century BCE
and the general emerging answer is that
wisdom or virtue is a practical
skill like what the what the great the
Greeks call the technique so it's
similar to let's say learning a language
or learning how to play a musical
instrument now how do you learn to play
a musical instrument you need ideally
three components other than the
instrument itself number one you need a
little bit of theory you you want to
know something about notation music
orientations and how the notes relate to
each other because otherwise you're kind
of going blind you have no idea what
you're doing
uh you also want a good teacher if you
can get a hold of one because the
teacher cannot obviously learn the thing
for you but it can point to places where
you might improve places where you're
making mistakes that sort of stuff and
then mostly you do you do practice
practice practice every day those little
simple scales first and the more complex
scales after and then simple Tunes more
complex Tunes Etc it's the same arguably
with virtue this has been something
that's pretty much been settled since
Aristotle and there is modern evidence
from Modern cognitive science that this
is a good way to to think about it so
what do you want you know you want the
theory for instance the Practical the
before cardinal virtues that I mentioned
earlier are part of the theory right if
you subscribe to a philosophy like
stoicism or or variations thereof then
you think okay that's a good way to
think about it in in general
ideally you need a good teacher I don't
see a lot of Socrates around
unfortunately but you know uh there are
people that can help you simply because
they're more advanced than you are there
there have been practicing for longer
than you are
in the case of stoicism for instance
there are large online communities and a
number of smaller in-person communities
scattered throughout the world where you
can show up and say hey I need some help
for the practice but mostly it is a
matter of practice now we all understand
how to practice a musical instrument or
a language it's a little bit more
counter-intuitive to say yeah but how do
I practice virtue exactly
and so let me give you a couple of
examples let's say that you figured that
uh you need to improve your Temperance
for instance right your self-control
then one simple way to do that is to be
mindful about a number of situations
where you know from experience that you
have trouble in terms of temperance for
instance every time you sit at the
dinner table you you know you eat too
much or you drink too much or you have a
a tendency to go overboard on things
well if you do it in a mindful way
they're not in other words before you
sit down to dinner you remind yourself
sometimes in writing actually okay
here's what I want to do tonight here's
how I'm going to handle the situation
for instance let's say you're going out
to a restaurant with friends so there is
the chances that you're going to be
pushed into you know by social uh by
social conventions to eat more and drink
more you can tell yourself you can set
yourself rules you can say okay whatever
the weather is going to put on my plate
I'm gonna eat half of that and I'm gonna
stop at two classes of one or something
like that once you do that then you
basically it becomes a challenge with
yourself you basically keep scores uh
you gotta kind of gamify the the
situation and there is very good
evidence again from modern science that
this actually works if you go ahead in a
situation like this
mindfully so knowing what might happen
and having decided ahead of time how to
behave your chances of actually behaving
in a temperate fashion are much higher
than there would have been otherwise or
let's say that you say well you know I
realize that I'm not really uh generous
enough generosity is something I need to
work on okay well then you can come up
with an exercise or let's say once a
week or twice a week
where you do something like before
leaving your house you put some pocket
you know changing your pockets and then
you give it to the first homeless person
that you encounter no questions asked
now initially
this is gonna look a little awkward like
really do I need to go to dinner and
write down ahead of time what I'm gonna
eat or do I really need to do this thing
about the homeless but with time it
becomes habit
it's like as I said learning a musical
instrument initially you have to pay
attention to every single mover your
fingers let's say on an alto sax which
is something that I try to master and uh
but eventually you get you see your
fingers just going on their own you know
you don't have to actually think about
it explicitly consciously they'll just
just do it and that's the same idea with
uh altering your behavior initially it
takes mindful attention but then
eventually becomes automatic well does
that make sense sorry yeah I'm just
going to finish this point they make
sense in terms of temperance and uh
generosity and many other traits that
you can practice and I I I've is
something I've focused on a lot in my
life and forced myself to to behave in
different ways and build healthier
patterns and so on I totally get that
but the reason I asked you about
practical wisdom is that that to me
seems quite different because that when
I look around at the world and I look at
my own behavior at certain points I
think that is a much harder skill to
gamify it is a much harder skill to
learn consciously because
um you you don't know that you're making
mistakes sometimes and you certainly
don't know at the time quite often and
especially you know one of the things I
hear out of what you're saying is the
importance of being present because if
you're not present you won't even notice
a that you are overeating or making
something a bad decision or whatever but
also if you're not present then life
sort of happens to you and you never go
well what was the decision that brought
me to the point that I'm at now that I
can actually learn from and not be a
stupid next time in terms of the bad
decision that I've made so how do you
how do you gamify and how do you
practice practical wisdom that's the
interesting thing to me yeah that's very
that's a good point the the thing about
paying attention is for instance
something that the second century
historic philosopher depicted is really
emphasizes he says nothing ever got done
better by not paying attention if you
get distracted from something you're not
going to do it better but yes the
question about practical wisdom is a
good one there is a fundamental
technique in stoicism that is also
adopted by modern Carnegie behavioral
therapists and the stoics refer to it as
philosophical journaling
the the CBT practitioner is probably
used some other term for it but it's the
same basic idea so this is a notion that
goes back at least 2000 years a good
example of it is microcellus's
meditations Marcus was a Roman Emperor
and stoic philosopher and he wrote this
book The meditations which is
essentially a personal diary it's a
philosophical diary where he asks
himself keeps track of of his progress
he asks himself what you should do and
and so on in fact it was not meant for
publication it was his personal thing
then eventually uh somebody got a hold
of it and published it so here's the
basic idea there's many there's
different ways of doing philosophical
journaling but the one that is most
common arguably is this every night
before going to bed you take about five
or ten minutes
uh get yourself into an area of your
house that is quiet
um if you live with somebody else you
know ask for five or ten minutes of of
peace and and open up your laptop your
tablet or you know Zeus forbid your
actual diary and where you're going
right in um
in handwriting and then for the for the
day think about any anything that
happened that might have been
problematic uh the body mean ethically
Salient where you might have made a
mistake or you might have done better
Etc and ask yourself three questions and
answered them in in writing one what did
I do wrong two
what did I do right three what could I
do better if something like this happens
again
here's the point
asking yourself why what what you did
that was wrong it's not about you know
self-flagellation and and regret and all
that because the stocks think that you
know whatever you did it's in the past
you cannot change it it's out of your
control so it's like it's done but you
do want to learn from your mistakes and
writing down thinking reflecting
critically about your mistakes and
writing them down helps fixing them
literally on paper and in your mind it's
like okay I need to pay attention to
this
he also want by conversely to write
about what you did right why because now
you've established two points of
reference what you want to get away from
your mistakes and what you're going to
work toward more the stuff that actually
you've done right and then the third
question in my mind is the most crucial
one actually
what is it that I could do better the
next time around if something like this
happens you know we tend to think of our
lives or perhaps some people think of
their lives as incredibly varied or you
know the same thing is never going to
happen again but in fact you know
we pretty much get up in the morning
during the week and go to work and see
the same people and do the same things
and then come home and seeing the same
people and do the same things and then
during the weekend we see friends
etc etc our lives are actually far more
stable typically than uh than we might
necessarily think so the notion is that
therefore whatever situation you made a
mistake in today let's say uh one of
your colleagues uh did something you got
really upset you got angry in a
disproportionate fashion you overreacted
or something like that oh you're past
did you know yeah exactly or your
partner or your children you know
whatever whatever it is that's likely
going to happen again and so what you
write in your diary is okay here was the
situation now let me think the next time
around I'm gonna be better prepared
because I know the symptoms I know
what's coming I have an idea of what
might happen and therefore I know how I
need to react that doesn't mean that
you're going to be doing it perfectly
the second time around but you are going
to be again it's about paying intentions
about mindfulness in that sense and so
there is actually fairly good evidence
again from cognitive behavioral therapy
and uh and similar approaches to
psychotherapy that this thing really
does work over but of course you have to
do it regularly I do it every night
every night but at least several times a
week and you have to do it over a
prolonged period of time it's just it's
like going to the gym you don't just go
there look around at the machines and
wait to pick up a couple and then say
okay I'm done I'm ready for the Olympics
right it's not it doesn't work that way
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we show an intimate moment as we watch a
Japanese tourists get trapped in a tube
door that is good but I wasn't talking
about their locals I was talking about
our community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you yeah you space
when you get to wasp incredible guests
like Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein
Bill Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Heather Hein and others your questions
not just that you can get supporter only
benefits like trigonometry mugs monthly
calls with our other top supporters and
even a regular meal with me and Francis
you also get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes footage of our trip to
America where we met a whole host of
incredible guests and gave ourselves
terminal indigestion we're also starting
to do monthly giveaways for locals only
the first one will be signed copies of
Andrew Dawes new book plus you get
access to an incredible community of
like-minded people who share memes have
fun conversations and most importantly
you get to make new friends you can
support us with as little as seven
dollars or about five pounds a month or
give us more for the higher tier
benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
and Massimo I've heard you talk about
this on several podcasts and it's very
interesting and to me I've
I don't think it's a coincidence that a
lot of these great philosophers were
also teachers because these are the
lessons that we should be teaching our
children and in fact we're teaching them
things that aren't going to help them in
life was very important skills like
these we don't teach
oh I couldn't agree more it's one of the
baffling things in in the my latest book
The the Quest for character I emphasize
that point there's one thing that we
ought to be doing which is teaching
character and virtue to our kids and
that is the one thing that arguably we
almost never do in fact it's so rare
that recently I've seen a documentary
that was done focused on one of the
exceptions to this general rule uh the
documentary is called young Plato and
it's about the principle of a elementary
school in Belfast in Northern Ireland
who decides that it's a it's going to be
a good thing to teach his kids these are
elementary school kids uh to teach
philosophy practical philosophy and
mostly Socrates and the stoics although
he varies a little bit and the movie is
incredible it's it's a documentary it's
incredible because you can you can see
how much practical impact that kind of
teaching has on the kids the kids
experience things like bullying for
instance and and now they have to figure
out how to react to it how to handle the
situation it's Belfast so these kids are
growing up in a culture that it's still
marked in violence and and in you know
religious strife and stuff like that and
so the the uh principle sits them down
and gives them a lesson in you know on
Anger Management from Seneca for
instance of course done at the level of
understanding of you know of a kid of
that age
but that kind of approach is so rare
that in 2022 we have a movie made about
it so it's it's not the kind of thing
that is very common and in my mind it's
it I think it's it's really bizarre it
really ought to be the standard approach
not only in school but at home of course
they also ties into biology as well
because it's also
just like learning a language or like
learning a musical instrument these
things are so much easier to do when
you're young
exactly in fact again the analogy is a
an apt one
yes you can learn a language or a
musical instrument as an adult but it
takes a lot of effort a lot of
dedication and you're not going to get
likely as good uh as if you study as a
kid and the saying goes for virtue and
for Behavioral modification character
modification yes you can certainly work
on it as an adult but it's going to take
you a long time and it's going to yield
a little bit of improvement if you start
on the other hand with kids of
Elementary School level then things are
very different and you know this has
been known for a while the ancient
Romans talked about the Age of Reason
which was about seven to eight years old
and that's when when uh fathers and and
teachers started talking to their kids
in about virtue and character etc etc
during the Middle Ages and Renaissance
the
um the Jesuits among the Catholics used
to say give me a child of seven and I
will give you a man of 14. because they
they realize that is that's the window
now modern science South actually tells
us there's some good news there that the
window is even a little longer than that
it does start around seven years old six
to seven years old that's the time when
kids begin to appreciate uh you know
abstract reasoning and engaging in more
abstract reasoning it's about six seven
eight years old depending on on the kid
but actually that window is extended
according to Modern Neuroscience until
your early twenties
because that is when your brain finally
settles down basically and it becomes
pretty much what it stays with you for
the rest of your life the human brain is
still very plastic so that's why you can
keep learning and and improving things
but the the broad uh scenario is pretty
much set by the early 20s earlier in
women in in girls than in boys
um which is explains why boys mature
later than than girls as you will most
most of us realize if you have a
daughter or a son you'll realize that
that is the case if there's a gap of
about three or four years but that only
means that you have three or four extra
years to work on boys
and so Massimo let me ask you a a
provocative question
uh if uh stoicism uh and I actually do
think this is true and it's something
I've I've implemented in my own life but
uh if stoicism is so good and if it
makes your life so much better uh why
when I look around at the world right
now when I look at you know politics or
culture or you know Francis and I both
former stand-up comedians I don't see a
lot of stoicism going on uh we instead I
see a lot of people being taught uh to
constantly criticize and complain about
things that are outside of their control
to to not act in a temperate way to not
seek uh justice and not to seek to treat
other people the way they'd want to be
treated but to punish
um you know we don't teach a lot of
practical wisdom and so on and so forth
and particularly in recent years it
seems to me you know in politics which
we talk about a lot on both sides of the
political Spectrum there is
um we we like to be victims a lot uh
it's something that We crave actually
and we've there are people who now make
this into an identity so how do you
explain all of this
well for one thing yes you're right you
don't see a lot of stories these days
although you do see now many more than
you would have seen 10 years ago or 15
years ago uh stoicism is definitely on
the on the rise and of course stoicism
again is not the only a philosophical
approach that is useful in this in this
case yeah I mean the values of stoicism
rather than stoicism exactly so for
instance if as I said before this is
very similar to Buddhism and there is a
pretty good number of Buddhist
practitioners around the world you know
uh but you're absolutely right there we
are in in a
find ourselves in a society where all
the incentives seem to go exactly in the
opposite direction and um the stoics did
notice that I mean the ancient Rome was
actually fairly similar to ours through
to our society today yeah there was no
Facebook or Twitter uh but nevertheless
it was still a society was pretty much
engaged into uh disruptive and
destructive politics it was all about
how much money or or stuff you had and
Etc et cetera so it sounds very familiar
the strikes of course blamed culture for
it their their distinction was their
their point was that look naturally we
are Cooperative animals we're social
animals and so if we want to talk about
because they didn't know anything about
Evolution but a modern primatologist
would agree that we have very strong
pro-social instincts because our our
survival depends on it you know that
doesn't mean we're always altruistic or
doesn't mean that we don't do things
that are good for ourselves of course
Twitter but broadly speaking human
beings are naturally pro-social they're
naturally Cooperative etc etc that's
what the historics meant when they said
that we should live according in
accordance to Nature right or in
agreement with nature we should take
seriously the kind of species that human
beings are and there are according to
the stories at least two fundamental
characteristics that that differentiate
us from most other animal species one
we're incredible as I said highly social
and the other thing of course is we're
capable of reason
and a very high degree much higher than
than any other animal species so for a
stoic to live according to Nature it
means to use reason to solve your
problems and to be social pro-social uh
you know Cooperative but they observed
the same thing and you just pointed out
that is yeah but majority of people
don't do that so what happens and the
answer was they're corrupted by uh the
culture in which they grew up human
beings are also very plastic in terms of
behavior they we absorb whatever culture
we grew up with and therefore the
problem as we would put it today uh is
structural
that is unless we change the structure
of society the incentives at a societal
level our value judgments our uh you
know objectives and the things that we
think are good to pursue are not good
then we're going to always have an
uphill battle now stoicism of course is
a personal philosophy of life just like
Buddhism or Christianity or stuff like
that so it is meant to help those people
who realize that hell this is not a good
thing the kind of place the the kind of
values that Society Shares are not good
so I'm gonna need a different framework
a different way of thinking about it and
therefore stoicism is useful in that
sense but if we're talking about
changing Society at large then we need
structural changes and that's a whole
different conversation because
structural changes are far more
difficult to implement uh than well than
individual ones the the reason obvious
uh just at least to me and again
provocative I hope you don't take this
personally as a stoic I know you'll deal
with it there's
an obvious flaw in that argument which
is yes human beings absolutely are
incredibly Cooperative but if we look at
the history of human beings which is the
best way to analyze how people behave I
think uh then what we would conclude is
human beings are incredibly Cooperative
while also being incredibly tribal and
most of the cooperation happens within
the tribe and a lot of the corporation
frequently happens in order to allow
that tribe to defeat another tribe or
allow that tribe to get more resources
than another tribe so isn't the problem
with all of this that actually human
beings are driven also by the tribal
instinct which doesn't really get taken
into account by these great virtues
you're absolutely right except for the
very last part again the stocks were
very aware of this I mean like they they
lived you know stoices started in
ancient Greece in Athens around you know
uh the fourth Century the end of the
fourth Century BCE and at that time the
Greek cities were always warning against
each other right so Athens versus Sparta
versus coordinates versus this versus
the other
so they were very aware of this notion
that people are prone to cooperate and
to help each other within group but on
the other hand they are just as equally
prone to you know beat the crap out of
of other groups
that is why the stoic notion is that
nature gives us as they put it the
beginnings of wisdom in other words it
provides us with a basic so pro-social
Instinct but by Nature we apply that
instinct and in fact there is an
interesting passage in Cicero where he
summarizes the histoic argument he says
that
by Nature we apply this Instinct of
cooperation to our caretakers you know
our
parents typically our siblings and then
eventually we start expanding it to our
friends and then eventually we expand it
to our acquaintances and to people that
live with us in our general community
and the story point is that's what
nature gives you that's where nature
stops then reason comes in and says yeah
but wait a minute the people that live
in Sparta are not different from me the
people that live on the other side of
the planet are not different from me so
I ought to
um
strive to expand further those circles
of concerns this is a notion that modern
uh utilitarians also uh subscribe to
like Peter singer for instance he has
this idea of the expanding Circles of
concerns but interestingly the first
time that we know in the in Western
history uh that that image of expanding
circles are concerned uh and showed that
the larger is Humanity itself uh the
first time we find that image is in a
Heracles who was a second century
historic philosopher so yeah these
people have been thinking about it but
they also realize that the idea of what
they call cosmopolitanism the notion
that we should be thinking of humanity
as a big family where we're all brothers
and sisters or whatever other gender you
subscribe to uh it's difficult it's not
it doesn't come natural it needs it
needs a combination of your natural
instinct which then is expanded
um on the basis of reason now question
is is this possible I think it is and
I'll give you one one argument may I
interrupt before you give me that mate
I'm just sorry Francis I just want to
kind of get to the bottom of this but if
I if I I don't know if it's a troop of
chimps or whatever the word is a group
of chimps a tribe of chimps whatever it
lives on a certain piece of land and
another tribe of temps shows up I
imagine they don't go uh you know let's
Embrace each other as friends and
brothers they go to war right so nature
also gives us that too doesn't it and so
it's not a culture that makes us tribal
and competitive and more like and
willing to kill each other it's also our
nature isn't it wouldn't that be true
to any stand it's certainly true from
chimps who however are of course
different from human beings because they
don't actually think about what they're
doing they go by instinctively but
here's what I was you're absolutely
right
um but there is a there is an important
Point here
what is the tribe
right we tend to think of a tribe today
as a fairly large group my tribe is you
know New York City I have I'm naturally
more sympathetic to people in New York
than to people outside of New York uh or
My Tribe could be the United States
that's a large tribe it's 350 million
people right there is the the World Cup
is going on right now and you know we
are all go USA what does that mean
that's a very large tribe that's not the
evolutionary tribe during most of our
evolutionary history our tribe was about
60 80 100 people at most and we're all
relatives most of them were relatives
cousins Aunts Uncles stuff like that so
our instincts are not actually tailored
for things like cities or nations or
anything like that they're tailored for
very very small group of mostly
relatives that is what nature gives us
so by culture we have already expanded
the tribe dramatically now we're talking
about tribes of millions or hundreds and
millions of people so we're already on
the trajectory the stoics would argue
toward cosmopolitanism all we need to do
is to go from hundreds of millions to a
few billions and then you then and then
you're good you're set
that's going to be difficult I'm not
suggesting that it's going to be
something that happens tomorrow but what
I'm saying is actually the historical
trajectory seems to be going in that
direction our tribes are getting larger
and larger and larger
eventually we might spill over onto
other planets and then I I I guarantee
you as soon as we start colonizing let's
say Mars uh we're gonna have the
earthlings versus the Martians and you
know that's going to be another tribe
but at that point it's a planetary tribe
right and so on so the process can keep
going so I think that that is a very
good objection but it's already
something that actually has been
happening our culture has started to
take over or to redirect our instincts
about 12 000 years ago with the
Agricultural Revolution once we started
we invented agriculture we started
settling down and and having creating
large settlements much larger than the
typical uh you know group of or band
that uh was featured in during the
pleistocene that's when our culture
started messing around with our biology
and then the notion is okay we want to
realign the two as much as possible
a Massimo you talk a lot about sympathy
and empathy let's have it let's have a
look at that the differences between
sympathy and empathy and why the stoics
actually had far more sympathy shall we
say for one particular value than
another yeah
so part of the problem with sympathy and
empathy is that actually there are
different and sometimes contrasting uh
definitions of the two terms but for the
term for the for the purposes of this
discussion Let's uh Define them this way
if you don't mind empathy is the idea
that you wanna
somehow put yourself in the shoes in
somebody else's shoes you want to try to
feel what that other person is feeling
you're going to try to it's so it's an
emotional response sympathy on the other
hand it's a little bit more it also has
to do with with emotions but it's a
little bit more intellectual because
it's the notion that well I might not be
able to put myself in in another
person's shoes but I am a human being he
or she is a human being so I can imagine
that she might not feel okay with this
or she might feel uh you know angry or
something like that so sympathy is a
little bit more detached but also
broader than empathy
the stoics are certainly about
cultivating sympathy but they're wary of
empathy and some Modern psychologists
are as well it was an interesting book
that came out a few years ago called
against literally against empathy
uh by Paul Bloom who is a psychologist
at Yale University and why why would you
be against empathy empathy you cannot
avoid empathy and if it's a it's a basic
natural human instinct and in fact
arguably you don't want to eliminate it
because otherwise you turn uh you turn
this into a bunch of psychopaths and
that's not what we want but the problem
with empathy is that it's easy and
easily manipulated
because it is mostly an emotional
response you can easily fool yourself
that you're actually in the you know in
somebody else's shoes while you in fact
you're not and even pretentious for you
to to think that you might be because
they have very different experiences
uh and you also it's very easy to
manipulate externally uh for instance I
don't know if you remember but um the
first Iraq when the first Iraq war was
about to start one of the things that
happened was that we were bombarded with
news of the Iraqi soldiers going into uh
hospitals and and throwing babies out of
incubators on the floor and stuff like
that and we all found felt empathy for
the suit for that situation in fact we
felt outrage for that situation too bad
it was entirely made up it was a it was
a you know uh a completely fake news
before fake news was a was a thing so
it's easy to manipulate somebody emotion
the idea with sympathy on the other hand
is that your cognition kicks in
uh the stoic model is that emotions and
cognition and reason are not separate
there are two aspects of the same thing
they're very deeply interconnected so
that you can talk to your emotions in a
sense and and reason with your emotions
come to terms with your emotions so
sympathy means that you are trying to be
uh helpful to other people you're trying
to understand how other people might be
going through let's say a tough time and
and how you might be helpful but at the
same time you realize you're not them
you're not you're not in that situation
and that puts you in a in a in a
different you know different uh from a
different standpoint you're looking at
things from a different standpoint so
yeah the stoics were very
wary of emotional responses or motion
driven responses especially anger or
fear or things like that but they where
on the other hand very much into
practicing sympathy because practice in
sympathy is precisely what it allows you
to expand those circles of concern that
we were talking about earlier I cannot
be empathetic with a billion people it's
just not humanly possible but I can
sympathize with let's say hundreds of
thousands of people who might be going
through uh the results you know dealing
with the results of a flood in in on the
other side of the world or something
like that and therefore I can help I can
do my part I can send money let's say to
some organization that it's helpful out
of sympathy but not empathy it's not my
experience I've never been exposed to a
flood I'm not on the other side of the
world it's just uh it's potential it
would be pretentious of me to say oh
yeah I empathize with people in
Bangladesh it's like I don't know
anything about people in Bangladesh
other than their people
and that's enough to trigger my sympathy
hey Francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium light
TV then simply sit back and watch all
your hard-earned money disappear down
the toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets 2 million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your advert will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing a
triggerpod DOT Co dot UK advertise with
us and we'll get your business canceled
at Massimo do you think that at the
moment we have a society that is too
empathetic where we essentially we allow
our feelings to override our logic and
our reasoning that makes us less stoical
and that therefore means that we make
ourselves vulnerable to be manipulated
by certain people seeking victim status
forever for instance as a way to raise
their status yeah yeah I think that's
exactly right and on this one I'm uh I'm
with Paul Bloom than I mentioned before
uh that's exactly the argument that it
that it makes against in in against
empathy uh yes I think one of the
negative turning point of contemporary
civilization for instance was Facebook's
invention of the angry button
uh which was not by chance at all it was
the result of you know careful Research
into what is it that can maximize the
number of hits on a particular page so
that I can maximize my revenues from
advertisements and uh Facebook
researchers discovered that the angry
button got eight times more responses
than a like button people like to be
angry people really fall for that sort
of stuff and now that is an interesting
example of structural change
you know we because that that the
introduction of that bottom as I said
was not random it was it was very much
on purpose and it was on purpose to of
course pursue the goals of the
corporation that is behind Facebook not
uh not to be helpful to humanity in
general or to be helpful even to the
individual user so that is one example
of how structural changes can hijack
natural tendencies and bring us in a you
know in a direction that we don't
necessarily want to go now how would you
react to that well I'll tell you how I
reacted to that I quit Facebook
right so because I used to think naively
as it turns out that you know
Technologies are neutral it it depends
on how you use them you can you know
nuclear energy yes you can certainly
build atomic bombs but you can also you
know power entire series out as a result
of it so it's neutral it depends on how
you use it that is true for some
technologies
but it's definitely not the case for
other Technologies
right and uh the case of social media uh
it turns out uh it's definitely not the
case they're not neutral neutral
platforms they're not it's not just a
matter of how you use it uh it's it's
there's something structurally built
into the system that biases behaviors of
many people not everybody necessarily
but a lot of people in a direction that
I think is destructive and so my
response was I'm done I'm out of it and
you must have experienced this as well
uh being a university Professor on
campus where you see empathy in inverted
commas getting weaponized empathy is a
means to shut down somebody who
disagrees with you empathy being used as
a way to like well we're not you I don't
want you to say this because this is
offensive this could harm this
particular person I mean that's another
aspect of this isn't it it is um I have
not honestly seen that much of that
particular uh phenomenon on on the
campus at city college but yes I've
heard from colleagues who certainly have
experiences something like that and I'm
wary of a lot of terms that have been
become very popular recently such as
safe spaces and uh you know oh that's
portfol and so on so forth well there
there are situations where a safe space
is in fact a good idea meaning a space
where somebody knows that they are not
going to be physically assaulted for
instance that's definitely a good use of
a self safe space but our University
campus if by safe space you mean a space
where you can present your opinions but
not subject to criticism that seems to
me to run exactly counter the whole
point of a university
right I mean some some time ago I read
one of my
um favorite writers from uh two or three
decades ago was with Neil Postman who
was a professor at Columbia University
and he wrote a great book called uh
teaching as a subversive activity
and his point was that if you don't make
your students uncomfortable at least
several times during the semester you're
just not doing your job you're not
you're not doing the right thing and so
yeah I don't I don't I'm really not
concerned with making my students
uncomfortable and they know it I tell
them in the beginning of the semester
it's like you know this is a philosophy
class the point of it is to make you
think about stuff that you don't want to
think about
and moving on to the idea of leadership
a lot of stoicism was focused on
producing you know good leaders now that
that you there's a particular example
that you that you talk about where it
didn't produce a good leader I can't
remember I can't actually pronounce the
name of the person but I'm sure you'll
be able to explain who he was so how do
we get better leaders and how do we
learn from the mistakes of the
civilizations in the past and the
empires that have crumbled
yeah that's a good question so in the
Quest for character I have two chapters
where I go through two different sets of
examples one group is philosophers
trying to teach leaders and Statesmen
about virtue and good behavior so to
speak and those are almost invariably a
failure
almost invariably uh Plato tried twice
with two different uh you know Statesmen
in Syracuse Dionysus the first and
Dionysus the second and he almost lost
his life in both cases it didn't work
Seneca tried with the Roman Emperor Nero
failure complete failure I mean that was
a pretty significant failure definitely
um
now Aristotle did much better with
Alexander the Great as it turns out I
tell the story in some detail in the
book that was actually one of the
success stories but by and large when
philosophers tried to come in into
politics and tell politicians how to do
things it's a disaster
the second group however is much better
these are Statesmen themselves
politicians themselves who realize they
want to do the right thing and therefore
they ask the advice and the support of
philosophers we have Marcus Aurelius for
instance who had uh you know Junius
rusticus who was a stoic teacher who
influenced them uh very much we have
Plato succeeded on on a third attempt
with his uh
student Dion who in turn did become a
leader in Syracuse and worked out much
better but that's because Dion sought uh
Plato not not the other way around uh
Cato the younger who was a Roman Senator
during the the period of the Republic
that also worked very well uh and Seneca
himself for one thing because he was
also a senator so what do these examples
tell you
that you can teach virtue to somebody
but you cannot learn it for that person
which frankly doesn't come as a surprise
to Any teacher I mean you know when I
occasionally get pissed off at my
students because I think they're not
doing you know making enough of an
effort that's exactly what I tell them I
can teach you guys but I cannot learn
for you you have to make the effort it's
again going going back to the analogy
that we were making in the beginning of
you know learning a musical instrument
you can have the best musical teacher in
the world but if you don't practice
every day and if you don't want to
practice every day in a mindful fashion
you're not going anywhere and you're
certainly not going to Carnegie Hall so
that's what we need now therefore what
do we do in terms of our leaders well I
think we do two things first we get rid
of most of the current leaders because
most of the current leaders are simply
not interested in Virtual character and
stuff like that they have their own
agenda uh and they're they're pursuing
in ways that are I think largely
destructive for the rest of us now you
said but that's that's a tall order it
is but if we're talking about a more or
less Democratic Society like most
Western countries are let's not forget
the buck does stop with us we are the
people that are like those people it's
it's very easy and and even satisfying
to complain about the the politicians
right it's like the politicians are like
Congress in the United States has a a
rating a favorable rating that is barely
above that of rapists as a class so it's
like you know it's an approval rate of
like 10 or something like that
because it's very easy to complain about
politicians but who the hell voted these
people in in there in the first place
and I understand that things are not
that easy because there are again there
are two structural problems there's
especially in American politics there's
a lot of money uh that comes from large
corporations basically a lot of our
politicians are simply bought by large
corporations so it's complicated but
ultimately we are the ones that cast the
vote and so it's our own damn fault so
before starting complaining about the
politician ask yourself well who did you
vote for last time around so that's step
number one getting rid of the people
that are there now step number two is
the long-term one and that's the one
that I was talking about earlier when I
mentioned the documentary young Plato we
need to work on our children We're not
gonna get a new generation of people who
want to act on behalf of society and do
the right thing if we don't teach our
children if we don't bother teaching our
children if we put our children in front
of an iPad so that we don't have to
bother uh you know being concerned with
them I see a lot of parents here in
Brooklyn New York going around with
their children allegedly they're having
their time with their children but in
fact what happens is that the parent is
on a cell phone and the child is doing
something else there's no interaction
there is no no coming together at all
because we're all busy doing other
things
most of those things being completely
relevant anyway so those are the two
things we need to change we need to
think much more carefully about who we
elect especially at a local level
because you know not I understand the
national like my vote in the national
election counts for close to nothing
especially in New York where there is
such a such a you know majority of in
this particular case Democratic voters
that it doesn't matter who I vote for
it's the Democrats usually get it they
can get elected the opposite happens of
course in other
states in the in the country
but at the local level that's a whole
different matter because at the local
level you know elections are one on a
number on a basis of hundreds or
thousands of votes and so not only one
vote counts but one person who contacts
a politician and and donates you know
gives money but wants to have some
conversation though those are actually
those actually make a difference and
before one become the becomes a national
politician usually often they start at a
local level so again it's it's up to us
but we need to do it in a concerted way
not just one one time we just need to
make it a priority and Massimo isn't
there another dimension to this problem
which is that
um you I agree with you that we're
responsible but I think the way that
we're responsible is actually less about
politics and and I've written about this
about the decline of we used to call
them the big beasts of politics here in
the UK they're not as many big beasts
anymore and I think one of the reasons
is you talk about social media and the
24-hour news cycle and whatever we've
got to a point where quite a lot of
politicians who who would have made it
in the past you know at Winston
Churchill I don't imagine would get
through the current political system
because you had too many pro the wrong
views he he drank too much you did this
he did that and he had these character
flaws that we might think of and so when
we find out that somebody said the wrong
word or was a bit insensitive or did
this or did that we filter them out or
the media filter them out for us there's
a massive outrage on social media people
get upset about this person said this or
did this or whatever and so you're kind
of left with the only people who you're
left with are the people who are
pretending to be perfect even though we
know that people aren't perfect but it's
it's more about you're not getting
anything wrong as opposed to actually
having virtue yes and no yeah I totally
agree with you the church you probably
wouldn't make it in fact it's kind of
funny that you mentioned this because
I'm just reading his biography and
because I wanted to get a much better
understanding not only of the men but of
his times I was in London recently with
my wife and we went to the war rooms and
the Churchill Museum so it was a great
great experience yeah I think you're
right in that in that department but at
the same time
at least in the United States and my
understanding is possibly in the UK
certainly in Italy of which I have more
uh of a direct experience
the situation is actually very
asymmetrical between the right and the
left at this point what you are what
your party the problem you're pointing
at is certainly the case in the left on
the left
uh you know in the United States here if
a left-leaning politician says anything
wrong and manages to somehow insult
somebody at whatever level they're out
there's there's no way
on the right it's exactly the opposite
the moral traages and insulting you are
the more you get ahead I mean you know
do I do I need to mention Trump yeah or
I think it's not on all of the right but
yes no I I know what you mean it's never
all done right I mean by the way but
here's where I it's not because I I want
to argue with you but just to disagree
we've had a conservative government for
the last 12 years a lot of the Damage
Done to the conservative party and the
government has been because somebody has
said the wrong thing or had the party in
the wrong place or was called doing this
or that so uh I I your point about Trump
is absolutely right Trump is a unique
individual uh in that way I think uh
there may be examples elsewhere of
people who on the populist right will
will go out and say something outrageous
and that will help them in the eyes of
some people I would also maybe argue
that you know Donald Trump probably lost
the last election because of how
obnoxious people felt he was too right
sir to me uh well I don't know about
certainly it's a little too strong
probably
um yeah but Trump is not and
unfortunately from my perspective it's
it's not an an unusual situation I mean
he certainly is the most egregious
example but he has started something at
least here in the United States so that
now we have like more than half of
Congress that represents that kind of
atos uh and that's damaging to the
fabric of society and so I see a
difference there as I said I'm less
familiar with the with the UK situation
but you know there are there are even
there there are there are limits to what
we should in fact accept uh from a
politician right so the question isn't
one of well you have to be careful what
you say you should be careful what you
say especially if you're a politician
the question is what kinds of things get
you disqualified right right so if to if
um uh what gets you disqualified is to
express a perfectly reasonable opinion
that happens to uh insult or or or
whatever rail up a group of people that
really should not be grounds for this
quality for disqualification but if what
gets you disqualified is the fact that
um you know you pass laws for the
country to behave in one way and then
you do exactly the opposite in your
private life well then you should be
disqualified of course then you know
that's a good reason for it so so it
gets it's complicated but certainly what
you're talking about is there it's it's
present
um and it is one of the many problems
that we've had and you know uh you
probably are know um Jonathan height who
is a yes yes uh social psychologist here
at NYU at New York University Jonathan
and I usually don't see eye to eye and
we've had disagreements uh even in in
print over over the years but recently
he has been pushing this notion that a
major source of our contemporary
problems is in fact the rise of social
media
because it is the rise of social media
that has made Trump possible but also
has made the outrage culture possible
the easily offended culture possible etc
etc and I think he has a point I mean
you know I don't know whether social
media is the beginning of the end of
civilization I certainly hope not but it
is a problem and we really ought to
fight back against against it now
fortunately Elon Musk is doing part of
the work for us because he's making such
a mess of Twitter that uh you know a lot
of people are actually living living the
platform but the problem is what is the
alternative
right so people are now beginning to to
to uh throw around ideas about oh
there's these alternative social
platform Etc yeah but we need to be
careful about considering whether the
problem is in the very notion of social
media and not the specifics of Twitter
or or Facebook or something yeah I don't
think you're gonna you're not gonna put
that toothpaste back in the tube I'm
afraid uh and actually I disagree with
you I mean I I know that some people are
leaving Twitter because they think musk
is making a mess of it I I think he he's
doing his best to try and improve it now
some people won't like it uh but I think
they attempt to improve it is better
than what we had before which was no
attempt to improve it at all uh we could
have a whole separate show about yeah
yes
we definitely could we're we're actually
on the hour so we will um we'll ask you
a couple of questions from our local
supporters that only that they will get
to see but we we do as always have a
final question for you that we ask all
of our guests which is what's the one
thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be don't
say Elon Musk now
um I think we're it's not that we're not
talking enough about it but sorry not
talking at all about it but we're
definitely not talking enough about it
and I'm sorry but it does have to do
with mask not him personally I think
we're not talking enough about just how
much of our alleged democracies are
actually plutocracies that is how much
money there is in politics and basically
buys elections uh one of my favorite
examples is a few years ago the federal
government was after Microsoft for an
Anti-Trust issue and what Microsoft
responded the way Microsoft responding
was simply to literally buy a senator
who introduced legislation which was
written by Microsoft to covert
Microsoft's f as and it worked so if you
can do that now you and I cannot do that
we don't have enough millions of dollars
to do that sort of stuff that it
undermines the market see in a really
serious fashion and I think we're not
talking about it enough about that well
said well guys if you've enjoyed this
make sure to subscribe to our local so
that one day we could buy a politician
but you're I'm asking I'm only joking
but you're absolutely right I mean look
at this uh what's this guys SBF or
whatever his name is yeah I mean he was
spending a crap ton of money trying to
influence politicians to basically
implement the laws that would benefit
his company we actually don't have that
problem as nearly as much in the UK
because uh you you can't really donate
in in the same way to political parties
and political candidates quite in the
same way
um so I I couldn't agree with him on
that uh before we let you go though tell
everybody where to find your books where
to to find your work uh and uh how to
access other things that you do
the books of course can be found
anywhere you get books online or or in
person for everything else Massimo peel
youtube.org you'll find all my
interviews podcasts videos links to
books and essays everything you want
fantastic stuff well thank you for
coming on the show we'll ask you a
couple of questions for our locals in a
second and thank you guys for watching
and listening we will see you very soon
with another fantastic episode like this
one or raw show uh all of them go at 7pm
UK time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
stoic managed to occur enough to want to
be virtuous but not so much that they
become overwhelmed by all the things
there are to care about
[Music]